[Music]  nobody should ever be blindsided  daytime icon Oprah weighing in on some  daytime drama et spoke with Winfrey at  the Tribeca Film Festival we had to get  OHS opinion on what our sources have  been telling us that Kelly Ripa was  totally caught off guard when she found  out Michael Strahan is leaving nobody's  told me that out there Oprah's certainly  thrived on her own and she thinks  Michael will do well at GMA I think  Michael is so great  he's like a natural talent we felt that  from the moment he sat down in the seat  next to her he won't get any sleep but  he will be wait was on hand to promote  her new series green leaf she stars in  it of course besties Gayle King was  there to support her and Gail has a  potential replacement for Strahan  if Ripa decides to stick with a co-host  but I wouldn't be mad if Andy Cohen was  sitting in the chair  I think Andy and Kelly would be great